what's going on sean chillin how are you
guys doing good welcome to the show
it's a it's amazing that uh
you know did you ever did you ever have
a desire
because before you did hot ones you were
a reporter like you were a journalist
and you you're doing interviews and
everything but did you ever have a
desire to be like a host type where it's
this is my
show yeah i mean i was a broadcast
journalism major and grew up watching
late night shows love line howard stern
so there was always a part of me that
thought maybe i could do this if ever i
got the opportunity but then as you guys
know it's hard to get those
opportunities it's not like you just
apply for that job but uh
backed into it by kind of just taking
advantage of every little assignment
somebody gave me and then it sort of
ballooned into this thing so in a lot of
ways like i have right now everything
i've kind of wanted to have and work
with people that are amazing so in some
ways that's true definitely getting the
opportunities is hard but the beauty is
when i've gotten them i've failed
it's always nice to make something out
of it right right that makes you feel
better because you realize a lot of
people stress about getting
opportunities for you you know it
doesn't matter if you get them or not no
it doesn't matter
this would have been done already anyway
it's two weeks i would have already
[ __ ] this up in the pilot
so how many how many things have you
done before this because this is like so
so successful were there other ones you
did that this didn't work uh no well
it's usually just sort of straight q a
interview stuff just packaging these
digital interviews just over and over
and over again doing stuff for print
whether it's like digital or magazines
or whatever um but this definitely blew
up but it wasn't as it wasn't like this
straight out the gate big
hit you know like our first couple of
seasons it was really a struggle to get
views and sometimes i was like wow i'm
really eating a lot of spicy stuff for
for no reason for no reason at all and
it's probably really difficult to get i
mean now it's easy to get guests i would
imagine because you're doing millions of
views but right when you're not doing
millions of views and you're just yeah
you do yeah you basically have to trick
people and uh you know early on that was
the thing we would just show up if
complex is doing a cover shoot with uh
with an artist like tinashe or something
we would just basically crash that uh
shoot and then say that we have this
add-on we have this show where we eat
chicken wings during the interview would
you be interested and then we were able
to get a lot of people to just fall in
that way by just going behind other
people doing things and collecting those
crumbs and then just sort of making the
show work uh and it is a lot easier to
book now but there is that caveat of
having to eat scorching hot chicken
wings which does turn some people off it
still stops some people
yeah i mean 50 cent for example that's
somebody who i think was made in a
laboratory exactly for our show
and i can't get him to budge you know he
doesn't want to do it or is it the wings
he doesn't want to do um
it's you know whatever it's muddy you
don't really know oh yeah that situation
but like him for example you know but
there's these white whales that we're
always trying to catch and yeah even i
think youtube has a certain you know
whatever if you're an established star
maybe even think of that oh i'd rather
do fallon or colbert or something even
like the podcast thing that people still
are kind of attached to not realizing
that youtube shows and podcasts are
doing the same numbers if not better
smoking yeah smoking some of those shows
so
yeah but i think that people are
starting to understand that more and
more and then that has all happened as
the show's blown up so we've definitely
benefited from that so you do like
what's the pepper that they said you ate
that's like the hottest pepper carolina
reaper that's the hottest one
well the what's funny about these pepper
guys is they're all like architects that
are trying to make the tallest building
and they're highly competitive and
they're all over the world and they're
all engineering these crazy peppers so
the carolina reaper pepper was the
hottest pepper forever and then some
farmer in wales did like the dragon's
breath chili and then the guy who grew
the carolina reaper who also grows
pepper x which we have in our 10th
hottest sauce he basically had this war
chest and he was waiting for somebody to
like dunk on him so he can dunk on him
oh he was ready yeah he was ready for it
and maybe he is for generations and
generations to come like who knows
what's in the war chest but it's same
with like all these guys they're all
like mad scientists well can this guy
actually eat the peppers that he makes
yes like a snack like it's canned oh he
can just
pop it up like it's popcorn catch it in
his mouth how do they determine how does
science determine which one is a real uh
the hottest peppers it's just reaction
or is there a way to actually tell so
there is a scoville scale which is a
measure of capsaicin per unit or
something so they can actually quantify
it on a scale like you would voltage or
whatever else so so for those that don't
know i mean hot ones obviously is sean's
show that's on youtube and it's shawn
and he sits down with a celebrity and
they eat 10 chicken wings that are
progressively hotter and hotter as you
know you do this like extremely well
researched interview
you know that people are struggling to
get through because by the time they get
to wing number six or seven everybody is
tearing up at the eyes and everything
you though
you come from this world like we said of
journalism and reporting so the
interview part was something that you
were doing before you got here but
now like jim is asking you questions
you're kind of expected at this point to
be an expert on hot wings
as if that's the passion but you were
not a hot wings guy before
no or even hot sauce you know it's not
like i
had this ability to eat super spicy food
and then was like this needs to be a
show you know that was never the thing
we were just trying to solve for a
problem like celebrity interviews are
boring how do we make them not boring or
solve for that hot sauce but that has
definitely happened and we've seen the
craft hot sauce thing explode because of
the show in a lot of ways and going
mainstream and now i feel like every
time you pass a fast food restaurant
you'll see some new spicy fries or spicy
chicken thing and so it's crazy i always
thought people would be more interested
in the interviews and like what comes
out sure and people just want to talk
about hot sauce and wings and take me
out for wings all the time that's just
what's happening can people has anyone
thrown up doing it
yeah we've we've run the gamuts we've
had people spit in buckets half pass out
sleep in the green room afterwards who
slept in the green room coolio slept in
the green room
[Laughter]
but it was funny because we used to do
the show actually like a block away on
50th street and it was in the middle of
an office you'd always have people
responding to emails and stuff and then
riff raff in a peach suit would like
throw his shoulder through the door make
a sprint for the bathroom and i'd have
people talk to me like i came out of the
stall and saw a riff-raff just
dry-heaving into the sink so those are
the stories that does make people sick
yeah what do they drink milk
milk
water well that's like the lifeline
though right right ice cream people uh
tire banks brought ice cream we've had
uh charlize theron delivered white rice
to the sweet that we were shooting in
you know everybody has an anecdote
gordon ramsay recently he stopped by
bristol farms before the interview
picked up lemon juice lime juice
doughnuts everything the gordon ramsay
one was great because gordon ramsay was
the first and this is something that i
think about when i'm watching the show
and i haven't seen every single episode
but i think gordon ramsay was one of the
few that pointed out that the wing he
was complaining about the wing itself
right like not the sauce he was like
there's no meat on this bone this is an
awful chicken wing which is the most
gordon ramsay thing you can do
you know right and we expected that i
had a lot of anxiety about it the night
before you know but is he one of those
was he before that one of those white
whales yeah definitely yeah i mean right
when we put up the first episode we had
all the in the comments
for from episode one until we finally
got him the top comments would always be
like get gordon ramsay get gordon ramsay
get gordon ramsay and then that bled
over into my real life i'd just be
walking the streets i'd be in an airport
and people be like when's gordon ramsay
hey chicken wing guy when's gordon
ramsay gonna be on the show so i felt
like there was an albatross around our
neck forever and then we finally got him
and i think that he understood the same
pressure because he was getting the same
stuff if he sent out a tweet when are
you going on hot ones whatever and
eventually the whole world pressured us
into that room well you guys had to be
happy with the way it came out it did i
mean i was looking at it last night
hey i think he did it
he did them all and it's done 30 million
views right so i mean
it's really tough to say that it didn't
succeed on every level right it did and
you know sometimes uh
we know a hit you know
it's like a singer that goes into the
booth and knows when they have a hit
sometimes we walk out of that room and
we know
that went well and we knew there'd be
ridiculous expectations for it we threw
the kitchen sink at him and he was such
a good sport when we walked out we're
like that was really good internet how
are the interviews too like because i
know you like to do the interviews so
like do people tell you more because
sometimes celebrities are [ __ ] weird
with giving up information they don't
want to talk oh it's a fun project do
you get more out of them because you're
doing something else i think that you're
trapped on the show and then every
person who does press whatever they do
the rounds as you guys know there's this
pr driven flight pattern that everyone's
kind of in and i think that the wings
are disruptive and stimulating and then
you're stuck on this show and you're
probably not thinking about your guard
rails when you're eating some of the
hottest chicken wings in the history of
the world
um but at the same time i think that
we're not even that kind of show you
know like we're not really trying to
poke the bear all that much because it's
not a clickbait show really right i mean
what's great about the show is that
there's less pressure on you to get
something newsworthy because the
headline is watch this big celebrity eat
these really hot wins right and i think
i think the secret of our success has
been in combining those things because
you already have this ridiculous
spectacle super famous people eating
scorching hot chicken wings on the
internet and then hopefully combining it
with this career spanning thoughtful
interview when those two things go
together i think that's why the show has
lasted now eight plus seasons how long
is the episode how long in between each
wing do people usually wait it varies
person to person that's what's kind of
crazy too because it's a revolving door
of guests and then everybody handles
spicy food differently if we all went
out for curry after this you know jim
you might get through it no problem sam
you might be sweating your face off i
might be puking in a garbage can next to
me so you know we have some guests come
in and they're like it just wasn't hot
enough and then some gas just be on like
uh death's door so it runs it's a big
range did that pepper when you ate that
pepper what did it do to you it was like
giving myself food poisoning for 12
hours it was insane it was so stupid and
then i swore i'd never do it again and
then i did do it again with the same
dude chili klaus but um
we uh i remember that first time i did
it
i was like something is seriously wrong
i went to a cab stopped at a cvs just
bought a whole gallon of milk and then i
went on my couch cranked the ac put on
some basketball shorts and i would just
be dumping the milk in my mouth and then
just holding it in there until it was
hot and then i'd spit it out and would
just do that for hours so
can it do anything really [ __ ] up to
you or is it just unpleasant i can do
something [ __ ] up to you i mean
sometimes i see these headlines because
i our fans always tag me in them or
that's like whales man chokes on uh
chokes on scorching hot pepper and
scorches his lungs you know whatever
like every bizarre i'm just making that
up bizarre i'm so scared yeah you really
got a blast in the sky
he could have said anything genitals
fall off oh terrible spontaneously
combust on hot peppers troy can you find
that whales man out of my eyes i need to
know more
um so whatever there uh there are some
things but i went to a doctor recently
because i was somewhat worried it was
one of these things where i didn't want
to go to the doctor because i'm like
they're going to tell me i have 100
ulcers and then if i do one more show i
might die and then just take away my
heat you know i'm like i'm going to
strike while the iron's hot mode i can't
have a doctor doing that to me so i
guess i just avoided it forever but
finally i was like i'm gonna be a
responsible adult i'm gonna go do this
they hooked me up to everything i was
like every blood test every scan
everything that you can do you know and
they hooked me up and then my doctor
called me up totally clean bill of
health so my numbers are outstanding
across the board so maybe they're making
me stronger these wings do you go out of
your way to eat healthy outside of this
because you need to maintain yourself so
that you can do this yeah this is a
lifestyle at this point it is yeah and
you have to think about that and even
the way the travel goes and whatever i
think you have to take care of yourself
more uh so people always think that i
want to eat wings all the time they want
to take me out for wings i'll go to this
hot sauce expo and everyone's like this
is the devil's blood you have to try it
everybody thinks that i'm just trying to
up the ante every time i turn a corner
but
when i'm not working it's a lot of juice
it's a lot of cereal it's a lot of just
taking it easy yeah i'm sure the last
thing you want to eat is wings that's
all you eat who the [ __ ]
if i'm off the clock i don't want to eat
wings let the records show i like to put
that out in the world but people always
it's like me they want to tell jokes to
you they're like dude try no trust me i
know a hot wing
or you know comedians that'll bring a
beer on stage or whatever and then
everyone wants to buy them shots yeah
it's like that i have that existence
well there's somebody hoping for a
meltdown that's why they buy the comic
shots because they're hoping that you
get drunk and [ __ ] up and it's a great
you know they're hoping for a michael
richard said unless you're unless you're
burke kreischer and you just say yes
every time that's why you drink
something
okay okay
that's a good bird it really is right
yeah but that's when drinking is a part
of your thing i guess it just doesn't
affect you if you get drunk it's like
all right well that's just bert's that's
first thing that's bert's thing who got
sick the fastest or who had the worst
reaction to it well eddie wong famously
started in reverse order to just
subvert the form and that was mistaken
yeah it is cocky so he started at 10. so
he was that was a crazy shoot because it
was like we fired up the cameras and
usually it takes a while before people
were like
and then you see the sort of
step-by-step gradual
uh
evolution towards that but eddie started
with the first one so it was like we
fired up the cameras introduced him then
he's eating the hottest camera and all
of a sudden he's doing laps around the
studio asking where the bathroom is
sweating his face off wow so he thought
he tried to get it out of the way and
then work your way into something
a little easier
yeah yeah and it didn't work it did not
work at all so what was the episode when
you knew
we are really onto something this isn't
just a hobby this isn't just a side
thing like this is gonna be big right
well like i said in the beginning you
know when it first started out maybe
we'd wake up it would just have low view
numbers but the people who watched it
liked it that's how i knew if we get
more people in the tent this will be a
big show because something yeah we keep
the same people week over week over week
who are like this is going to explode
this is the best show so that really
fueled us early on and then uh the first
episode that we ever did where we woke
up in the morning and it was five
million views number one story trending
blah blah blah was when we had key and
peel in
and that was just something that uh
worked i guess they were doing a press
for keanu i remember we crashed the
junket shot with kian peale put it out
and that was the first episode that just
totally blew up and then helped us level
up and it's kind of just been a runaway
train since then it's amazing yeah do
you have any uh and yeah i'm not gonna
ask you for names but do you have any
you said you know when it's like this is
internet gold yeah do you have
interviews that you've done and the
whole thing's over and you've gone
through all the wings and you're like
that was a dud what are we gonna do with
this i mean it's happened a couple of
times a couple of times famously if fans
are thinking like if a fan was in here
they'd talk about the dj khaled episode
where you only ate two or three wings
and then bowed out you know you're like
found out he didn't do the interview or
he left he stayed there but he's like
i'm not eating any more wings
and uh like dj khaled like the whole
point is so you could do your catch
phrases and eat very hot wings right and
i knew in your track suit i knew right
away that it was it was going to go that
way because when he came in he's holed
up in the studio and he was just
crushing slices of pizza so i'm like why
is this guy eating pizza before we're
about to tell you yeah why is he trying
to coat his stomach i don't know what
the move was i don't know if it was a
strategy or if he was hungry or what she
wanted some pizza but then he bowed out
uh but to me i really like that episode
because it's such an outlier and it's so
strange uh from a viewing experience
perspective than like every other
episode so i mean it does say a lot
about it but it says a lot about dj
khaled because
most people try to come on and impress
you and impress the audience and want to
be the ones that go far dj khaled is so
impressed with himself he was like [ __ ]
all that he just doesn't see the need
which i almost respect you know which i
almost respect yeah yeah so you have to
eat the whole wing or just part of it
it varies you know are you strategizing
i'm just curious how you handle
something like this yeah we're not like
the olympics you know i think that if we
started putting strict rules on it and
hitting people with like the house rules
and then introducing them and it would
get like competitive yeah and then like
who weighs the who's the referee that's
like that's not enough of the wing to
qualify yeah so for us and people are
all different some people you know we've
had guests that are 70 years old and
stuff like i wouldn't even feel good
about them crushing who have you had on
those seven jeff goldblum
jeff goldblum is that's the price
goldblum is a young 70s that's crazy
that jeff goldblum is 70. yeah wow
that's a fascinating guy um sharp too
yeah yeah so there's been so for us
whatever if you take a bite you take a
bite if you kill if you clean the wing
the audience seems to respect that more
yeah i mean i understand that yeah yeah
and i do like the people who come in who
don't know anything about the show and
are just like i'm gonna crush all these
chicken wings i'm cleaning them all
because they're taking it as a real
challenge but if somebody comes in and
they don't and they aren't like that and
they're just giving the interview
biting and still struggling you know if
you just take a bite out of that hot
sauce you'll really feel it so
to us it's not that important how much
of the wings you don't care it's more
the reaction if they're trying to do it
right i think that if somebody nibbles
and they're like i'm cool i'm chill this
is fine blah blah blah it's not even hot
then that to me is kind of lame but
right if they're at least trying i'm
cool what is how what's it acceptable
you said after three is no good what's
an acceptable amount to get through when
you're like all right this is a good
interview even if he can't do any more i
to me it varies person to person so i
think that if you commit and you try and
you're into it if you bow out at six or
seven or eight we have lil yachty on the
show and he'd never had hot sauce before
in his entire life that's what he said
in the intro and he's like i want to be
here today because i've never had hot
sauce in my life and this is how i want
to do it which i think like one of our
commenters compared to trying to learn
how to swim at niagara falls
and so he went in and he actually made
it to eight which is further than most
people who bow out in the show do so to
me that was an awesome performance by
lil yachty you know you can't yeah yeah
yeah you can't mark them down burns your
lips that [ __ ] burn you get on your
lips when you need hearts oh and imagine
experiencing that for the first time on
a show under
camera lights in front of a crew you
know with the hottest of hot wings the
hottest chicken wings in the world now
uh when little xan went to the hospital
and said it was for flaming cheetos
uh did you hear that story he was eating
all the flaming cheetos
and he went to the hospital are you
going like this is not good for business
if people are going to the hospital for
eating flaming cheetos what is this
going to mean for wings i immediately
was like this story's fake you know
nobody goes to the hospital for flaming
hot cheetos and i think it's semi-soft
right uh-huh a bag of flaming hot
cheetos not a big deal i don't care
where you're at if that sends you to the
hospital
that's not you i feel like yeah you just
felt unpleasant and panicked that's what
that is
right so
what xanax cool but flaming hot cheese
hot cheetos that's what puts you in the
hospital part of me feels like he did
not go to the hospital and flaming hot
cheetos decided to pay for a story to
break and that's everybody went with it
that's what i think oh you think that
that was a thing by the company yeah
that was a that was a windowless room
filled with cigar smoke illuminati
situation yeah who's been the most
competitive on the show like who comes
in and you're like you don't you need to
relax because it's just me and you here
you don't need to be like this well
athletes all have the same mentality
every time we have an athlete on they
always have that even we had
i think next week's episode is jimmy
butler and even when he took the milk
he's like how much milk do i drink you
know they're very
very serious they don't want to break
the rules yeah they're very serious
about the rules and then even you see it
in their face they're like
four more you know it's like they're
doing
they're in the weight room that's like
they're like one more second there's a
goal there's there's a way to achieve
the goal there's a way to pace yourself
at the end and there's a mentally a way
to hack that i guess for them yeah i'm
not competitive like i just give up
quickly
man-to-man competition you know what i
mean if i see the guy and he's bigger
than me like i can grab
you
so if you're sitting there you would be
the dj khaled of this if you're like you
know what this isn't as positive as i
thought you approached it i would i
don't know i mean i would try to do more
than three but i don't know i mean uh i
would maybe not no if i just puked i
puked but i mean i would prefer not to
puke right you think you should go it
might happen really i don't know are you
not good with spicy food i don't know i
don't know if i am or not i know i got a
very sensitive stomach i'm very bad on
planes i get motion sick i won't eat
sushi before i fly because i'm afraid of
getting queasy
in the same way that athletes are
competitive comedians are neurotic yeah
you're right
right that's that's what i've noticed
with the wings now would you try to do
you know
jim and i we won't spoil it for anybody
we we filmed a certain
television show that takes place in a
bar that needs help um
recently and we did have to work around
the fact that jim
doesn't drink
so we had we had to figure something out
we told them when we arrived by the way
we're doing a blog show i don't drink
alcohol
i think i guess on the headset
we didn't tell him in advance no
but do you uh would you try to say like
look you know i'm kind of on a health
kick right now i don't really eat wings
is there something else no oh yeah just
maybe maybe do like a maybe like a
deep-fried collar celery on the spices
no you got to do it they show it but i
don't know how many i don't i don't know
my stomach can be at times very uh
tricky it can it can wow i hate to hear
that yeah friend in the bowl but would
you go full throttle would you push
yourself yeah i would try of course you
know i don't know how many i could do
but i would try i wouldn't want to be
lame yeah it's like you don't want to be
but i'm not an athlete either i say to
the surprise of no one there's no reason
to say that but i wouldn't i wouldn't be
able to recommend it like i'm gonna do
six i'm gonna do eight you know right
those guys have the ability to push
themselves beyond what i do that's why
they're athletes as successful as the
show is do you get like are there any
points where you get worried like oh my
god like all they need to do is just get
some guy who can ask questions and eat
hot wings they're gonna replace me or do
you realize
you know the fans watch the show because
i'm the host of the show like do you
have that confidence or are you like
many of us that go
i'm very replaceable and they're gonna
figure this out soon it's a little bit
of both where i think that anybody
that's doing something in entertainment
you always feel like you're going to
lose it you never get it back um but i
also think this is my baby i'm obsessed
with the show and have been since the
beginning i mean that's pretty clear
when you look at how it's like
branded and how kind of big and beyond
just a youtube show it's gotten yeah
yeah i think that
you know whatever if somebody wants to
eat these scorching hot chicken wings
and commit to the show like i do and
then make it a better show then i would
just tip my cap to that but i don't
think it would happen i don't pull a jim
norman bow out
i just yeah i'd hand over the reins but
to me whatever i don't i've had such a
freakish drive with this show and i've
been with it since the beginning and i
know it and i know the audience and the
way that i spend almost like every
waking hour whether it's travel whether
it's research whether it's doing the
show or in post the way that i just
helicopter parent this show i in the way
that i've committed to it and i do
have confidence in myself as a host and
interviewer i don't i'm not worried
about i wouldn't worry about that i
don't think anybody make it a better
show honestly what are you a fan of
cause you have you have athletes
musicians actors wrestlers comedians
they've all done it and every interview
is heavily researched like we just said
and they're all none of it comes across
like you're not informed about the
person that's on and what it is that
they do but what
kind of of those categories is okay
we're in my wheelhouse this is going to
be this is this is a layup well i think
that part of what's made the show work
is that i i have a hobby with walking a
mile in someone else's shoes so to me
the process is a hobby in the hobby you
know the it's both ways where i like if
we're going to interview someone and i
know we can advance i like that i'll
listen to their album i'll read their
book i'll watch their shows i'll listen
to their stand up i'll do whatever and
totally immerse myself in that world for
as much time as i have before the
interview
and i actually enjoy that i would do
that for free you know uh and
did do the show for free for a long time
but uh so to me that is whatever i'm
into the process i like hanging out by
pools when i'm in la i like going out i
like going i like hanging out with my
friends i watch a lot of college
football hype for the tournament you
know i have those sorts of interests and
hobbies but to me i just do love the
process of the show and then just being
intellectually curious uh has made the
show
i think that that's what's made the
interviews so authentic in that regard
what made you want to do journalism at
all like
you know i think about this sometimes
but i just started out by listening to
the radio so even when i was in junior
high i'd have tapes of howard stern i'd
listen to love line constantly every
night i'd go home i'd leave parties to
go listen to loveline i think part of me
just
wanted a radio show i wanted to be like
those guys my dad he'd watch letterman
every night when my mom was out on uh
out on work trips or whatever i could
like stay up late and watch letterman
with my dad and he would uh explain the
jokes to me every time the audience
laughs so i think that there was all
that combined with you know that nature
nurture mix and
i think that's why i pursued it i wanted
to do broadcast journalism because i
wanted to make videos on campus and have
it go towards my degree and then
took off from there what did your
parents do
my mom was a paralegal my dad's a judge
oh wow wow so when you
when this show starts obviously it's not
the thing right from the beginning but
when this starts to become the thing how
long did it take these people who have
these high esteemed professions to
process the fact that you're the
majority of their son's income is going
to be coming in from the hot wing show
yeah well it's a weird thing because
you know my dad doesn't watch youtube so
to say i'm moving to new york to be on
youtube right because your dad's sitting
there watching letterman you're like i'm
gonna have my own show he's saying what
channel is it on and you're saying the
internet yeah
yeah the computer look at watch it on
your phone right exactly right you know
the thing that anybody can have a show
on i'm going to have a big show on that
i'm going to have a show and then uh so
he was just it was a bit of a head
scratcher maybe but he was super
supportive
and i think once we started getting
people on that he knew like ricky
gervais for example then he was like oh
this is kind of cool and this is awesome
and then you know when i was on colbert
because he was such a letterman fan to
be in the ed sullivan theater you have
colbert spitting milk on the stage at
the ed sullivan theater i think that was
validating for me and him and how crazy
is that to not only i mean it's
validating enough to be invited to be on
colbert's show but he wants to do your
bit
on his show yeah like with this we've
created a monster here this is it's tot
i think of it as ludicrous it's
completely ridiculous you know this dumb
idea that we had to see it grow the way
it has and that was such a milestone for
us and then i remember just the way they
have
uh a food artist
displaying the wings and how it's so you
know they're that those shows are really
like a swiss army night you know the way
that everybody's working together it
just it looks great it's like a kitchen
and a three-star michelin restaurant or
something the way that everybody's
moving around so even when they're
laying out that table the way that the
band was playing when you walk by and
then we just walk to this table and eat
scorching hot chicken wings on cbs it
was ridiculous it was insane did you
find like a no-nonsense guy
no he's got a good sense of humor and i
think too i think when you're a judge i
think it makes you because people are
always like oh could you never get away
with a lot blah blah blah but i got away
with like a million things sneak out of
the house like whatever all the time uh
because i think maybe when that's you're
nine to five maybe you kind of want to
just go home and get your ass kicked by
your kids and stuff you know you don't
want to be regulating all the time when
you're a kid like are you like not
worried about getting arrested because
your dad's a judge uh well i think that
i was
just good at avoiding that detection i
think i was i'm moving in the shadows or
whatever but the funny thing is that
friends would call me all the time you
know when they got like scooped up with
something or they'd be like call in the
house be like hey can you ask your dad
but kind of not say it's me you know in
these roundabout like drinking tickets
caught with weed or whatever they'd
always call my house ask for legal
advice would he help him
yeah he'd kind of be like
you know just casually yeah if he knew
the guy yeah yeah did you ever want to
do law no never and uh my parents didn't
seem to want me to either how come
i don't know i just realized that it was
hard work and it probably isn't going to
pay off so skip it they never they never
pushed in any direction that way they
were just kind of they were chill about
it i wanted to be a lawyer a comedy
first but then i was like that's never
going to happen so in high school i kind
of wanted to be a lawyer after injustice
for all you know what russian al pacino
i'm like that's a great job but you know
it's ironic you graduating from law
school probably has less of a chance of
happening than having a career in
stand-up yeah you're probably right
yeah that was pointed out to me quickly
when i dropped out of high school now it
is rehab
yeah my parents i mean they were
you want to think it's supportive but i
i know i looked on their face when i got
into syracuse
the shock
that was on the face of both of them and
well yeah you got to go let's go let's
go let's go like they realize syracuse
is going to figure out that they made a
horrible mistake here clear clear why
would you get into this school yeah yeah
they sent me away so it was probably the
same thing they were like yeah you know
this this law school thing it's not
it's not for you yeah or not you know
you don't need to right right right so
what did you do in journalism besides i
know you wrote for a tr it was a travel
uh
yeah so that was my job after i uh after
i left whatever after i graduated
college i ended up working at this
agency that did it's not super
interesting but like out of market
advertising for destinations and i was
in chicago so i worked for the chicago
tourism agency where we do if you ever
go on a subway and you'll see like visit
montana or whatever and there's like a
picture of a buffalo or something we
would do that but for chicago so i was
doing that but then on nights and
weekends and basically all my free time
i was just doing freelance articles like
just keeping my eye of the tiger
interviewing like local chefs or
athletes whatever if somebody wanted to
do a derrick rose feature or whatever i
might be like the local guy who would do
that so right i was just doing that
doing that doing that ended up doing
some stuff in new orleans for all-star
weekend where we had all these cool
interviews lined up and it was right
when complex launched their youtube
channel so they were like hey can we
just send cameras because we need to
start uploading videos so can we put
these interviews on camera and i didn't
have any big dreams or anything i was
like yeah that would be the coolest
thing ever to just have a two chainz
interview on youtube i thought i'd pick
there and that would be the coolest
thing that i did and then it's still
pretty cool it is cool yeah and then
they liked him enough to offer me a
full-time job so i sold all my [ __ ] i
quit my job left chicago i was in new
york
30 days later and that was almost like
five years ago to the day so when you're
writing copy you're a copy editor for
these travel but you have to get people
interested in like one quick shot right
you have to write so what do you write
for chicago that makes people go [ __ ] i
want to go there well the key is
the key is to just go to millennium park
take a picture of that bean thing and
then just be like uh
you're home now or something and then
just put that in an airplane magazine
and then you're good to go so and you
did something that they rejected but
they're like that's a terrible no one's
gonna come here because yeah but
what we used to do i think is chicago
they rioted no no
i'd make whatever we do basically what
you do is you do like 10 different
versions of the same thing and then
throw them up there and then have
somebody pick one
and then you feel like you have your
bases covered okay so you've done a
little bit of everything yeah yeah i
would just show the willis tower i mean
this year's tower that's just kind of
what i like about how tall this is yeah
it's [ __ ] high right yeah i looked at
the top did you ever go to those windows
with those things those glass things
where you look down i can't do that one
of my earliest memories is going to the
top of the sears tower back when it's
called the sears tower and taking that
view in i do remember that and i must
have been like three or four years old
at the time but uh i never went in any
of those boxes i don't think i have the
stomach for that someone for hot wings
not for that i thought it would be fine
i went out because it's like it's a
glass blocks like the little kids go in
there everybody does and it wasn't until
the minute you were there it wasn't
until the minute that i stepped in
and i like collapsed like i could not
your knees started shaving every stomach
dropped everything i had to hold on to
everything around me but you did step
out
yeah i i did really quickly and then
right back in it was really embarrassing
you realize how much it would suck to
fall
that far i read something about the guy
who jumped off i had actually figured
that earlier that if not when you're
seeing it when you're seeing it it's
like i had read something where a guy
jumped off one time i knew chicago was
so windy and it took him like 12 seconds
to fall because the wind was so horrible
just try to think about something else
on your way down yeah that's what i was
thinking of as i was sitting there
looking down it would take like 12
seconds yeah crazy i love chicago such a
great place i know i'm talking about
suicide you have a fun show
have you had anybody that's done the
show
maybe even early on that kind of
complained about it after like i didn't
want to do it why
it's actually surprisingly shockingly
usually a very positive experience more
so than anything else i've worked on i
think i think
people think celebrities might be uh oh
they're two whatever they're gonna turn
their nose up or but i think most of
them are just normal people that are
like i'm killing these wings they'll
push their team back a little bit
sometimes like do you need one and
they're like no i'm in it i got it i got
it i got it so even afterwards and uh
what's crazy is it becomes this weird
clubhouse where now even i'll have i'll
still be in contact with people that
have done the show a lot of people
actually so that
i think you end up building it like a
it's like a buddy cop movie every
episode is amazing what you have to go
through to to get to certain people like
entourages are very funny to me like you
travel with one or two people some
people literally walk around seven nine
people yeah make up people the trainer
and there's so many people to get
through to get to that one person and
when you're sitting with them they're
just like yeah just let's do it right
they're usually easier to deal with
that's what i find too even when we're
trying to pitch people or whatever
sometimes i'll talk to somebody like
we've been trying to get you in here
forever and they'll be like what are you
talking about i've been wanting to do
this show and you just realize there's
gatekeepers that are crazy that's crazy
i mean you want to think and it never
happens but you want i feel like if i
found out something like that where a
person was like i've been trying to do
this forever and i go i have no idea i'd
be furious at the gatekeeper right like
i at least want to be able if it's a no
let me say no i always think that about
publicist i feel like that's like the
most worthless job yeah in this in this
place because if anything
the bad ones are automatic vibe killers
yeah you know so i always that's
i'm gonna pop on a publicist in this
calendar year i'm saying that right yeah
yeah yeah they can be very difficult
because uh there's a times where it's
not reasonable what they're saying like
no we just want to do that and they're
speaking for the artist but it's like i
know you're not representing that person
right right they don't know we're even
having this conversation yeah yeah and
you'll be like i host this show trust me
i know what people want to hear what
they want to know and it's not anyone's
goal to make anybody look bad isn't that
weird when like a publicist won't
realize
no
the way this is gonna work is when we
all look good and i'm gonna make them
look good that's the whole reason
they're here and it's all based on
chemistry whatever this is the first
time that we're meeting today and we
have to create this fire between us this
chemistry between us and then when
somebody comes in and just messes up the
vibe it even messes with that so i'm
like you know if you would have just
stayed home this would have been so much
better yeah because they interfere when
they necessarily should what what do
they do to you they start telling you
like he doesn't want to talk about this
or she doesn't want to talk about that
or well don't mention the divorce or
whatever it is you know we don't
whatever if somebody so he doesn't like
wings
yeah he has a sense of stomach could you
just interview him and then send him
home no yeah i think that
with us the guardrail thing usually
isn't a major issue and usually if it's
something about family or relationship
or whatever you should just respect it
if you're going to have your guests in
any way um but the things that i'm
thinking about is early on especially i
remember one person came in and they
were like this isn't a phoner what a
blah blah blah you know like that uh big
star and they were they didn't even know
they were going to be eating chicken
wings that day they thought it was a
phoner
yeah
and then and so and we do our due
diligence because we're always we always
want people to know what the deal is
they're eating scorching not chicken
wings because otherwise you're gonna set
the whole thing up they're gonna show up
this isn't what i thought it was i'm
leaving and then they dip right yeah and
you're screwed have you had anybody get
uh i just used your term i've never said
dip before you sounded really cool
shitty chameleon
and then two she's walking and with hot
ones do we do this career spanning
interview where the plugs up front the
front plugs in the back so we have it
set up to where you know we have a lot
of space to play and you'll always know
that you'll hit your
talking point and we deliver this big
long 25 minute interview to the world
without commercials and everybody's
happy so uh
but i remember she's walking around
she's like why isn't why isn't he
talking about the movie what is that you
know like that and i could hear her
and like you know what i mean it's just
messing everything up
that way thank god for that room right
there and travis in there being our
gatekeeper because he tells us and it's
happened multiple times
we're having a conversation like this
right we're not necessarily
talking about the project but within the
conversation our audience is becoming
interested in you and we're gonna we're
gonna mention why we're all here but the
publicist will be in there talking to
travis and going
they're not talking about the project
are they gonna bring up the project they
haven't mentioned yeah right it's like
you stupid [ __ ] what do you think
everybody wants to hear an actor go yeah
the director was fun oh that's
fascinating yeah right 15 more minutes
of that they're not talking about the
children talking about the pranks you
pulled on set
[ __ ] [ __ ] the the publicist
it is the worst the worst because they
don't understand that like if people are
interested in you they'll be much more
interested in what you're talking about
and what you're selling because they
like you yeah and part of you being
interesting is just having a
conversation or whatever it is a hundred
percent and the bad publicist really
the public system stays out of the way a
bad part sees the vision some of them
are good i'll i'll say that some of them
are good maybe they'll see the vision
and understand that and know that and
support that and then some of them don't
i've had this in the middle of an
interview they'll walk up and look like
and they put the paper down and it's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing would
you do that if you was on conan right
you walk out right right yeah but good
publicists know
that most publicists are bad so like
they'll hear this conversation and a
good problem will be right on yeah right
on yeah by the way you brought me a gift
thank you what's the gift i don't know i
didn't know i brought some t-shirts i
brought you some hot sauce oh thank you
that's very exciting
yeah
and i'll try it
just take it away no no i can't have to
fly i'm not doing it before playing
smart yeah it'll actually get sick yeah
and nobody wants to be on a plane
with those kinds of issues you're
already bad enough with your gut health
on a plane i know as soon as we're done
with this interview i'm gonna [ __ ] for
20 minutes i'm gonna run upstairs and
[ __ ] like an animal is there anybody
that you've uh had on or maybe even
haven't had on but interacted with where
they will come up to you at this point
and go like
they're not that they're just saying i'm
a huge fan of the show but you can tell
they actually are like they have they're
citing references they're talking about
favorite episodes where you're going
holy [ __ ] you're a fan of the show yeah
that happens all the time and when it
started to take off you know i'll always
know because sometimes people walk in
and i'm like hi i'm introduced and
people are like i know who you are i've
seen every like t-pain came in and he's
like um episode
61. you know
i've seen every episode it's funny that
you brought up bert earlier because uh
bert was our first real famous fan who
was tweeting out every episode and well
bert's like so great because no matter
how famous he gets he's
he's a fan boy he's a fan boy before
he's a comedian before he's a famous guy
before he's he's a fan boy exactly and
he's the and it's the best right so then
we've had that whole thing i'm trying to
think of other
tom segura yeah you know uh i've been
fortunate enough to keep a relationship
with him going after this and kind of a
person i'd go to if i needed advice on
something so that's all been so awesome
uh
yeah it's amazing that you start to
create networks right and it's crazy how
the network just sort of like i feel
like it was just all under water and
then it just starts to float and then
you just see how
you're just here now yeah yeah so you
want 50 cent is the guy you really want
who else is somebody that you're dying
to get on
well the fans i feel like they've gone
from gordon ramsay and then once we
cross that off the list i've now
brought out other names you know so i
feel like i'm always just chasing that
chasing my own tail trying to uh satisfy
the audience right now big names are
elon musk or
the rock or you know so those names that
pop up all the time i bit the rock you
might get the right
after that smoking on rogan i don't see
him doing anything else risky but yeah i
don't see elon musk doing a whole bunch
of youtube shows yeah anytime soon i
think yeah especially if you were like
you know we like this we like to smoke
weed when we eat way yeah oh yeah
me too what's this like a marijuana
cigarette yeah but i thought he would
take the joint though i bet he would he
would take that he still would he wants
to be cool
he does but i i i wouldn't be shocked to
see the rock pop up on that show
one time uh because we've been pursuing
him forever one time
i got a note that was like would shawn
be open to eating grilled salmon strips
and i was like we're close because that
had to come out of his mouth yes you
know so i feel like we've been close
well would you do it
yeah
for the rock yeah i mean if somebody
comes on and they're vegetarian or
whatever we'll get vegan wings or oh
you've done that before yeah so we'll
we'll meet people halfway on whatever
dietary uh
thing they have it's really about the
sauce so the vessel isn't that totally
grilled salmon strips will be just as
hot as
chicken wings yeah grilled salmon strips
soaked in hot sauce just as much and
then i guess you'd do that for the rock
you know but for the rocks i would say
of course yeah i've been obsessed with
the rock's [ __ ] instagram it's the
best dude every sunday he has a cheat
meal and sushi that's my goal in life i
want to eat sushi see the squats he was
doing yesterday on instagram no oh my
god
what do you mean it's just the way you
said it
wasn't that kind of homoerotic
no
well sorry that i'm not watching his
food porn oh look at the meals he gets
there
i
well i want to do squats with the rod
you want to do there's nothing wrong
with squats over the rock
first of all the rock would be doing
squats
no he had like he had like a ton of
weight on him and chains hanging down
and everything his calves were i mean
look whatever you obviously prefer the
sushi picture would you go to him would
you go to the iron paradise and do it if
you wanted to what's the iron yeah we
should know if you're a [ __ ] fan of
the rock
why are you being so hostile do you know
what the iron paradise is dude not
that's his portable gym that's where he
works out all the time he brings it on
set and everything so like on the movie
lot he'd just drop the paradise out they
had that i'm not sure they build it from
wherever he goes he has to have a gym
and he can't just go to the gym he's the
rock and probably he has very limited
time to travel yeah i would say if if
matteo lane can't go to uh hotel rooms
the rock probably has issues he may have
played at four in the morning before he
shoots or or eleven at night when he's
done who knows whatever his schedule is
but he doesn't have to worry about that
he wants to just walk in work out and go
yep yeah you're just sucking up to the
rock because he watches comedy netflix
specials on his instagram i know he does
but the bottom line is he uh he i i want
to eat uh i don't know what i've never
met him you haven't talked and not but
i've never met him
he is it infuriates me but he's a jim
norton fan well they will eat together
well listen uh if anybody hasn't checked
out uh
hot ones yet i mean i'm sure that you're
aware of it if not it's on youtube first
we feast is the channel but just look up
hot ones uh well is shaq the newest one
shaq is the newest one and then we have
theo vaughn coming out
that's great yeah that's a really good
episode so we're happy for that one and
then are there any do you announce in
advance any other guests for the season
well some
it's just fans are kind of suffocating
so if they know a guest is coming down
the line then they'll just spam the
current interview with like where is
theo oh yes i swear is that i see but we
got a theo von
jimmy butler and then two more episodes
in the season and then we'll start right
back up again how long do you take a
break between seasons like 20 minutes i
mean
you know like maybe 10 days uh yeah feed
the beast right it's been so crazy i
mean that's
you know we started this show
a little over three years ago now we're
eight seasons 150 like we're nailing
every thursday at 11 a.m for basically
three four years and you love doing it
though so it's not like work like it's
fun yeah i mean sometimes you get a
little bit
you know it starts to weigh on you know
a little bit because of all the travel
and then sometimes the way the show
works uh maybe we have a big bank where
we've done a lot of interviews and
banked them maybe sometimes we gotta
catch up so then you just start stacking
them all in a week traveling all over
the place people give you [ __ ]
suggestions like do you want to get you
to get the queen
i have a hard time even looking at my
twitter you know but yeah obviously the
queen or just yeah just ludicrous
requests all day every day are you going
to do a a wings restaurant
i mean that's the move right that is the
move a chain a chain of wing restaurants
that's that that's aspirational yeah i
would say hot ones whatever like fast
food wings
let's partner that's it it's a layup i
got i got all the connections no problem
i go to chipotle at least twice a week
so it should be fun okay i know what i'm
saying yeah you know fast casual
that is the term did you see nbc had
this i can't believe you just said fast
casual nbc had this reality show that
lasted one season i love where you're
going with this did you travis and i at
to up to this point i believe were the
only two that watched it
three yes it was america's next great
restaurant or whatever these guys are
trying to make a restaurant and they
have the chipotle yes and then what he
would always say whenever he made the
rounds because they're giving feedback
you know the judge is giving feedback
he'd always like have you tried a fast
casual
you know all he knew was chipotle so all
of his advice would be chipotle related
of course you'd just be like have you
tried serving this as a taco
you know
his only point of reference to
everything is just what he'd done with
chipotle and he was so just laser
focused that was just what he knew why
did the show work i mean i loved it i
they lasted the whole season
that was a good show i think the final
two i mean i remember soul daddy was the
one that won and i think that the
restaurant lasted like 20 seconds
nothing yeah they opened it
here in new york yeah it did it lasted
no time at all nobody was one lunch
service and then it was folded you know
it's interesting you'd think on a show
like that like if it were a big show on
shark tank for example even the
businesses that fail succeed right like
they don't get a deal but the show is so
big that they still succeed as a
business but not one restaurant from
that show succeeded joey's balls or
whatever the meatball place yeah
yeah it was uh that was
yeah that was the kiss of death being on
that show yeah yeah i wish i could find
that show online or on dvd or something
classic i didn't watch every episode it
was good all right there's three of us
travis doesn't that make you feel good
it does
hey is this true with the what nick is
saying in new york
uh find out nick in new york what's
going on
uh yeah guys thanks for having me on uh
sean i've heard that hot black coffee
cuts heat better than milk have you ever
heard that or tried that
i've never heard that people always hit
me with antidotes all the time
on paper
i don't know about that
you know i mean i'm sure that's true and
then if they put it through whatever
scientists yeah i bet that's true on
some level but if i'm eating a scorching
hot deathwing i'm not reaching for the
coffee coffee maybe the acidity does
something does it have to be hot nick
uh that's what i had heard the hotter
the better
i'll give it a shot i'm gonna give this
a shot and i will report back to you sir
uh but even like water they always say
water doesn't work but uh
psychologically there's something about
ice water that i feel like helps me
maybe they're just [ __ ] with the
person like i got wings hot coffee
yeah yeah seriously we'll throw if i
throw it in my face trust me it helps
this would be good this would be good
want more jim and sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
sirius xm app